hey youtubers is charlie so this is
gonna be my Deadpool trailer breakdown
Ryan Reynolds said they would release an
official version in about three weeks
just because they're finishing visual
effects that's the only reason they
haven't posted the official version yet
the same leak and release thing happened
with Warner Brothers Suicide Squad
trailer I literally just did a video for
that because Warner Brothers gave up
their life here's the official version
we don't want to keep trying to take
everything down because we can't repost
the trailer I'm gonna get a little
creative here with the breakdown so it
starts with him before he became
Deadpool he's Wade Wilson talking to
girlfriend Vanessa Carla played by
morena baccarin and she's using like
everything this year including Gotham
she's gonna be a series regular on that
show cancer is pretty much taken over
his entire body he has this funny line
where he says you're right the cancer is
only in my liver lungs prostate and
brain all the things that I can totally
live without then it cuts to him
entering the Weapon X program and asking
them to do right by him most people have
recognized that that's actually a line
from the Green Lantern movie he was in
so the throwing serious shade at his
really bad Green Lantern movie whether
or not you actually thought it was bad
as is up to you some people liked it I
thought it was ridiculous it was
actually like there were a bunch of
names attached to it like the people
behind arrow and the flash and stuff but
the script that they wrote for it was
gutted by the studio so technically like
you can't blame Greg Berlanti Marc
Guggenheim those guys their script is
not what ended up getting shot it was
like another person that they brought in
so giant thumbs up for the really
awesome Green Lantern joke some of the
details of his backstory are probably
going to get left out just because they
have to fit the entire story in a
two-hour movie and the reason that he
winds up in the lab where he becomes
Deadpool is just a little bit different
but i did a separate video explaining
that so i'll put a link in the
description if you want to learn like
the true comic book origin of Deadpool
and then and then it goes to like the
footage that we saw in the leak test
trailer like the one with him on the
bridge taking out the people in the car
then we see Deadpool calling Colossus a
big chrome gobbler as Colossus
knocks amount then we get to meet
negasonic teenage warhead this is the
first time we've seen her she's right
out of the deadpool comics his character
even has the line that's the coolest
name ever then we get the obligatory
Deadpool you know breaking the fourth
wall moment where he turns the camera
says cue the music and in there
like this sequence where he goes to a
strip club has sex with Vanessa all the
really crazy stuff in the movie then we
see weasel addressing dead Poland in his
full costume saying you look like an
avocado that had sex with an older
avocado he's talking about Deadpool with
his mask off with his totally messed up
face then in the last scene he kills a
whole bunch of people turns to camera
and says i'm touching myself tonight so
you can see even though they're changing
if you know a few minor details from the
comics it's completely true to the
energy of the character in the movie
that they made you as much as it breaks
the fourth wall in the in the tradition
of deadpool acknowledges that the fans
are the reason that the movie got made
seriously it all started with that
leaked trailer last year the movie
itself the project was completely dead
until that happened and then Fox was
like okay you know all these people
clearly want this let's see about doing
something you also have to give a big
thumbs up to ryan reynolds who doesn't
need this project even though he hasn't
had like his Makana sense where he has
had this big comeback he still makes a
ton of money so he didn't have to do
this project he did say though that
after this movie is over he's not going
to be playing any more superheroes he's
like I'm done with superhero movies take
him or leave him I mean he's done a lot
of comic book stuff all the way back to
blade Trinity which is funny because
heat wave from the flash played Dracula
in that so let me know you guys think if
you've had a chance to see the leaked
trailer I can't share the the footage
here because Fox doesn't want to post it
yet Reyn Reynolds said it about three
weeks they will release a high quality
version if you remember like like
suicide squad that trailer leaked they
kept taking it down after about 48 hours
Warner Brothers just gave up there like
okay we we can't keep taking this down
this is too much work so we'll just post
it so don't forget in a couple weeks
we're gonna get a nice shiny version of
this let me know if you think about some
of the actors though like I mean are you
excited to see morena baccarin play
copycat that's actually I mean I know
all about Ryan Reynolds we've all seen
Ryan Reynolds play Deadpool and we've
seen the test footage we have not seen
morena baccarin yet if you're on the
fence about her she wouldn't keep being
cast and all these different things if
she wasn't amazing at her job so she
should she's a great actress so I think
it just depends on what the script is
usually that's the problem with a lot of
superhero movies is that they have like
a really good idea in the script is at
least okay but sometimes actors get
miscast for the most part though I think
the superhero
genre is starting to mature a little bit
better actors are more open to playing
superheroes now don't you just wondered
like Ben Affleck was just announced to
be directing and co-writing the next
Batman movie don't you just wonder in
his head if he's like hmm I think we
could do like it like an Oscar candidate
movie like an Oscar candidate Batman so
I'm still working my way down the comic
con trailer list next is going to be
arrow season 4 that'll probably tomorrow
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything after I make it through all
the trailers I'm probably to start doing
character videos so hopefully most of
that stuff will be done by this weekend
and then I can start doing batman arkham
videos again on my game channel white
guys wait for that stuff you can click
here to watch The Suicide Squad trailer
again and you can click here to watch
the flash season 2 trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you